liebe isar germany zuschauer wir haben
heute etwas ganz besonderes für euch in
den vergangenen monaten haben wir uns
gefragt was wir tun können um eure
lernerfahrung mit easy german noch zu
verbessern und wir haben etwas gefunden
und wir freuen uns sehr dass heute mit
euch zu teilen wir wissen dass ihr aus
ganz unterschiedlichen gründen die
deutsche sprache lernt manche von euch
sind gerade nach deutschland gekommen
und ihr möchtet möglichst schnell die
sprache dieses landes lernen andere von
euch sind deutschlehrerinnen oder
deutschlehrer und ihr benutzt unsere
videos in euren schulklassen wieder
andere von euch lernen deutsch zu hause
einfach als hobby oder als spaß und ihr
freut euch mit diesen videos deutschland
zu sehen
ihr alle habt eines gemeinsam ihr mögt
unsere videos weil ihr dadurch kontakt
bekommen zur deutschen sprache und
kultur
ihr seht die deutsche sprache so wie sie
tatsächlich auf der straße gesprochen
wird
aber wie können wir diese echten sprach
situationen von der straße nutzen um
noch besser deutsch zu lernen
mit unserem team haben wir in den
letzten monaten übungen entwickelt zu
unserem episoden das ernste sieht so aus
wir haben für jede episode ein
übungsplatz mit ungefähr sechs bis
sieben seiten entwickelt hier drin
findet ihr zum beispiel eine vokabel
liste grammatik übungen und diese
grammatik übungen gibt es in drei
verschiedenen levels immer zwei übungen
für anfänger zwei übung für
fortgeschrittene anfänger und zwei übung
für fortgeschrittene und am ende die
sagt übungsblätter findet ihr die lösung
dazu dieses erste ebook mit übungen zu
zehn verschiedenen easy german episoden
haben wir heute an unsere unterstützer
geschickt im letzten jahr haben uns über
250 personen geholfen
easy german als projekt auszubauen ihr
habt uns geld gespendet und wir schicken
euch als dankeschön
dieses erste buch aber auch diejenigen
von euch die uns noch nie unterstützt
haben können einen einblick in unsere
übungen bekommen
auf unserer website haben wir die
übungsblätter von drei episoden als
download für euch bereitgestellt
das ganze findet
ihr auf easy german dot org / heftig
exercises diese übungsblätter möchten
wir in zukunft jede woche für euch zu
jeder neuen episode produzieren
das heißt am sonntag findet ihr eine
neue episode easy dörnen und am montag
bekommt ihr die übungsblätter zu der
aktuellen episode damit wir sie dämmen
weiter professionalisieren können
benötigen wir jedoch eure unterstützung
wie ihr wisst steht hinter easy german
kein großer medienkonzerne oder ein
verlag wir sind nur eine handvoll
freunde die zusammen dieses projekt
produzieren weil wir spaß daran haben
euch beim deutsch lernen zu unterstützen
und das möchten wir auch weiterhin
machen
wir möchten unser projekt nicht
verkaufen und uns geht es auch nicht
darum möglichst viel geld mit dem
projekt zu machen
aber ist es eben wichtig für uns dass
wir mit diesem projekt auch unseren
lebensunterhalt verdienen können
german ist unser beruf sowie ihr
elektriker zahnärzte oder lehrer seit
und es ist ein beruf der uns spaß macht
nicht nur weil wir ihn uns selber
ausgedacht haben sondern weil wir wissen
dass er gebraucht wird und wenn wir an
einem samstagabend mal wieder bis spät
in die nacht daran sitzen die
übersetzungen zu schreiben oder die
untertitel einzufügen
dann machen wir das genau aus diesem
grund weil wir wissen dass ihr euch
freut am sonntag ein neues video zu
bekommen ihr seid teil dieses projektes
genauso wie wir ihr seid nicht nur
unsere zuschauer
ihr seid auch unsere arbeitgeber ihr
macht dieses projekt möglich denn wenn
ihr nicht wert dann gäbe es dieses
projekt und unsere motivation gar nicht
und darum starten wir heute die 500
pence challenge sobald wir 500 pence
haben werden wir jede woche diese
übungen produzieren wir möchten 500 von
euch überzeugen ein teil dieses
projektes zu werden wir wissen dass das
möglich ist denn wir haben viele von
euch getroffen und gesehen wie sehr ihr
dieses projekt wirbt darum bitten wir
euch heute wenn ihr regelmäßig easy
german schaut und wenn ihr dieses
projekt mögt dann werdet bitte ein
mitglied bei easyjet
und ermöglicht uns dass dieses projekt
eine stabile zukunft und eine stabile
finanzierung hat ein erster schritt auf
diesem weg sind unsere easy german
exercises denn wir möchten unsere videos
weiterhin umsonst zur verfügung stellen
gleichzeitig können diese exercises uns
helfen mit dem projekt ein wenig geld zu
verdienen und eben unser projekt damit
auf eine stabile basis zu stellen also
wie funktioniert das ganze wie werdet
ihr mitglied bei easyjet in ihr geht
einfach auf patchen dot com / german
dort findet ihr unsere seite wo ihr
mitglied werden könnte ihr könnt euch
anmelden mit einem dollar pro woche oder
mehr und dann seht ihr ganz normal
unsere videos wie immer auf youtube aber
ihr bekommt jede woche ein ganzes paket
mit sachen dazu dazu gehören die
transkripte unserer videos in deutsch
und in englisch dazu gehören die vokabel
listen und auch eben die übung mit den
lösungen dazu also das was schon für
heute und wenn ihr uns helfen möchten
unser projekt weiter zu
professionalisieren und auszubauen dann
werdet bitte mitglied von uns das ganze
bedeutet uns sehr viel und es wird uns
helfen eine sichere zukunft mit dem
projekt zu haben
wir danken euch jetzt schon für eure
aufmerksamkeit und sagen bis zur
nächsten woche
[Musik]